JENNY BROWN: Our
last video talked
about some major
configuration options
when using the Cloud Talent
Solution Job Search API.
There are some simpler
configuration options
that we have recommendations
for and some best practices
when testing out
your API integration.
Let's start with the
configuration options
when executing a search
request against the API.
First up, page size is
a pretty simple one.
It's number of jobs that get
returned in a single response.
We typically recommend
sticking to 20 or fewer
to keep things quick.
Now, if you're dealing with jobs
in multiple geographic areas,
you'll want to make sure
that you set the region
code through location
filters and language code
for each search.
The search's region code will
match the jobs region code only
to display results
in the right regions.
For example, if a
region code isn't set,
a search for Cambridge
might return job results
from Cambridge in the UK
and Cambridge in the US.
The language code will help the
API localize the search query
to increase the
relevance of results
through language-specific
terminology.
Not only can you set the
region for searching,
you can also set a
distance in miles.
Setting the distance to 50 would
limit the search results return
to only be within 50 miles of
the user's indicated address
or lat long.
Like most of the
configuration options,
you should tweak this to what
works best for your use case
or expose an option to the user.
The fewer restrictions you
place on the query results,
the more results you'll
get, but potentially
with less relevancy.
There are also some
configuration options
you can set on individual
job postings to help the API
when searching, such as the
location we just mentioned.
When setting the
location of a job,
you should provide the
address of the job,
if possible, rather
than the GPS coordinate.
We'll go over more
details in future videos
when we talk about
creating jobs in detail,
but the API uses
addresses to help
with location detection
and accurate results.
In general, making
sure jobs have
locations helps users
have a better experience
when searching.
For each job, you can also
set an expiration time.
After that time, the job no
longer appears in results
when performing a search.
By default, the
expiration time is
30 days after the job is
created in the UTC time zone,
but you can change the value
for each job as necessary.
Again, we recommend
making sure to set
this property to what makes
the most sense for you
and your users.
There is also an
employment type to help
make sure users have more
choice about what types of jobs
are returned.
Typical values can include
full time or part time,
but there are a number of
options to help narrow down
what can be returned,
and not all options
may be applicable to you.
Finally, there's the
custom attributes property.
This allows you to add
additional values to each job
so that you can filter
by them as needed,
or to use with custom
ranking, like we talked about
in the last video.
For example, you may
want to filter by GPA
required or industry type.
Now, we don't recommend setting
up any custom attributes
for location-based properties.
That's because the API already
has location logic specific
to the location field on
a job that we've already
touched a bit on.
With those configuration
options in mind,
you'll have a way to
better control what
jobs get returned for a search.
There are also
some best practices
when designing your
integration with the API that
are worth noting.
Make sure you do your best to
avoid uploading duplicate jobs.
While the API has
protection to make
sure nearly identical jobs
don't show up next each other,
it's still a poor
user experience
to see the same job
listing multiple times.
When creating a job in
the API, it automatically
gets rejected if it's not unique
according to a few parameters.
Two jobs can't share the
same combination of company,
requisition ID, and location.
Again, we'll look more at these
when we go over creating jobs,
but make sure to avoid any
job duplicates before trying
to create them in the API.
Speaking of errors,
you'll also want
to make sure you've set up
your integration to have
appropriate error handling.
When running any requests,
make sure to check
for the error codes in case
the request didn't go through.
Some common errors
we've seen are
cases where the job
location is set incorrectly
when uploading a job or when
required fields aren't set.
You can check out the full
list of all response codes
in the link below.
When debugging or
investigating an error,
we recommend starting with
your local logging sources.
You can then check out to Cloud
Talent Solution Management Tool
to see what may have happened.
It's also possible
to setup Stackdriver
to collect all the metadata,
metrics, and events
that you'll need to debug.
If the error code is
related to quota or sending
too many requests, you may
need to check the Cloud Talent
Solution Console, which you can
access through the Google Cloud
Console for any
indexing restrictions.
It's good to know if you'll be
limited on the number of jobs
you can index at any given
time before you upload any jobs
and to prepare accordingly.
When handling an
actual error, we also
recommend doing exponential
back off for any retries.
There's another link in
the description for this,
but the basic idea is to
ensure you design your system
in a way that doesn't just
spam the API with requests
after a failure.
These are some high level things
to keep in mind as you look
to start integrating your jobs
and data with the job search
API.
In our next video, we'll
walk through the details
of data that gets
sent to the API,
such as jobs and companies.
Thanks for watching,
and remember,
when looking for talent, it's OK
to keep your head in the cloud.